okay okay good morning good night
welcome to this joint audit and
standards committee I am councilor Dave
Muller and I am chairing the meeting
today
may I first of all remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
one please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use two that you
do not interrupt other speakers three
but if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave and
fourth please switch please ensure your
mobile phones are on silent or Switched
Off
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and we'll be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film or photograph
and broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
I now like to make some introductions
the officers attending the meeting today
are Jane Kennedy the corporate manager
for policy performance Insight risk and
Improvement good morning Jay
Teresa fairbaum risk management League
good morning Teresa Rebecca Hewitt
corporate manager of finance
commissioning and procurement good
morning Rebecca
our Jon Snow corporate manager for
internal audit risk and data protection
morning John and Randy who's our
governance officer and Jan Robinson who
is the Deputy monitoring officer
can I move to the agenda please
um
are there can we have apologies for
absence and substitutions please
substitutions
uh thank you Chad so we have um
apologies uh from councilor Austin Davis
and councilman John Matheson thank you
very much and do we have any
Declarations of interest from members
good
okay item three is to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 25th
of July 2022
these are for accuracy of the minutes
only and could I have a proposal and a
second of please
character e-burn and councilor Huron
thank you I would now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic votes
thank you
chair that boat is now in progress for
you to vote
chair that's five votes four and two
extensions thank you very much
Right Moving On I move on to item four
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme thank you item five questions by
the public
thank you and item six okay questions by
councilors
thank you very much therefore we move on
to item seven which is the Jack Jack
2136 risk management Improvement report
and I'd like to ask Jane Kennedy the
talk manager to um
present that report please
catch the Morley
thank you Jim may I make a myself and
councilman crook would like to
like some introduction yeah thank you
very much yeah can I also introduce the
leader of mid-suffolk District councilor
councilor Susie Morley and the cabinet
member for baber is Alistair mccrawal
thank you
thank you chair apologies in April 21
2021 our external audit Partners
TIAA undertook a review
management Arrangements and they
identified some good practice in our
risk management framework and made
recommendations to improve including an
updated risk management strategy
this report updates members on risk
management Improvement since
responsibility for risk transferred to
the policy performance Insight risk and
Improvement team in January this year
following this change the senior
leadership team agreed to adopt a whole
systems approach to risk management
known as the government's orange book
this government approach will help us
improve the culture and Leadership of
risk management across the two councils
further in March 2022 the council's also
received back on our approach to risk
management in the LGA corporate peer
challenge report one of their
recommendations was to revisit the risk
management strategy and bring it to life
to ensure a more effective corporate
approach to risk including Financial
Risk
members of the Jac on the 28th of
November as today and the cabinets were
later on the 9th of January are being
asked to consider the effectiveness of
the revised risk management strategy to
deliver the appropriate risk management
Arrangements the new strategy includes
the recommendations made by the TIAA and
the LGA and it embeds the government
orange book risk management principles
strategy is supported by an improvement
program to embed risk across the
councils establishing a positive risk a
culture rather of risk management and
continuous Improvement
I'd like to hand you on now to the
corporate manager uh Dr Jane Kennedy and
then after that and to the lead on the
matter of risk management Teresa fair
then
thank you thank you members
um so
um as councilor Morley and counselor
McCall said
um
whisk came over to us my team in uh 20
20.
22 this year as part of an integration
with Performance Management
the reason why SLT has adopted the
orange book is because it drives an
holistic approach to to risk management
and enables us to integrate with
performance and finance
we are still driving through the process
so we've re-established to risk register
on a quarterly basis going to SLT and to
Cabinet as per the Constitution and
we've established a risk management
Improvement plan and brought in Teresa
as our risk management lead who can
drive who's driving through risk
equipment and what you've got in front
of you is the paper that sets out what
we've been doing to to Through The Years
so far and also a draft risk management
strategy that takes into account the
record recommendations of Tia the LGA
and integrate the orange book principles
and throughout the strategy
thank you
very much Jane do we have any questions
for Jane please
um thank you chair
um thank you for that
um introduction I've got quite a few
questions
um but I'll just start with a couple the
one of the things that's raised is about
aligning with the culture
um
and um
so I'm just trying to find my page
um so I bottom of page 20 align the
council's culture with risk management
framework I didn't guess don't get sense
how that's going to be be done and
equally within that
um what's the kind of structure in terms
of of the the team and how that sits in
the organization
just leave it there for a minute thank
you
um thank you so in terms of the
structure of the team I AI team is a
policy it's a two policy and strategy
leads performance lead risk lead a
continuous Improvement Aid
and then people sitting under a
underneath those leads what we're doing
at the moment and what choice is put
into place and can talk to you about is
a risk management Improvement plan and
as part of that we've set up
directorate level risk management
conversations and are working with
service managers corporate managers to
help them to understand what risk is a
business what issues are and to
establish risk management practices
throughout all levels of the
organization
also set up a risk management fora so
that we can understand and support each
other through the Celtic system in terms
of risk management choosing but do you
want to say anything more about
culture
and thank you I have met with most of
the service areas now they're all using
a new risk template which aligns to the
orange book and the tier recommendations
almost all of those service areas have
migrated into the new template now we're
also going through an upskilling program
as well to get everybody at a certain
level in terms of knowledge and ability
and there will be educational resources
that are available for everyone that
will be tailored to need roles and
preferred learning styles as well
risk is going to be embedded into
employee performance and further work is
in progress to meaningfully integrate
risk into reporting alongside our
finance and kpis
so all of those efforts will drive a
culture of positive risk management
across the councils and baber and
mid-suffolk have also been instrumental
in setting up a risk management Forum
which includes Suffolk County Council
East Suffolk District Council West
Suffolk District Council and Ipswich
Borough Council to discuss Horizon
scanning current listings sorry chair
sorry to interrupt but we've got a
problem with the live stream at the
moment so okay just pause for a minute
sorry to cut you off
still right
oh the computers just gone
right okay okay
so as I as I said we've set up this
forum with the other Suffolk councils to
discuss Horizon scanning Uh current
misthinking and support one another in
achieving best practice and Baba
mid-suffica also now represented through
membership of alarm which is a
professional membership Association
supporting risk management professionals
across Public Services
thanks
um thank you for that and and further on
in the report page um important page
that 33
um refers to members
um
you know all elected members and staff
members proactively identify risks and
so on so forth so I don't have you know
what's the what's the plan for for
members or to ensure that um or members
of the council understand
responsibilities as far as risk is
concerned thank you
so as part of the Education and Training
there will be training options for
members and through the through the LGA
and and obviously I'm very happy to run
bespoke risk management workshops and
answer any questions and support as
necessary
if I can just follow up to that so what
we're planning to do
post post selection in May is to ensure
that jazz and cabinet particularly have
responsibility people have direct
responsibility and members for risk are
fully trained on risk management as part
of the induction process and all members
have some training
um
process I'm working with FD at the
moment through Jan to to put that in as
part of the induction plan
um thank you chair that then
the
other area is on um so page 26 when we
talk about the companies and the
um
the district council's holding companies
and the saying that the governance
process and responsibilities of risk and
so on so forth
where where do we see that
um we don't you know there isn't any as
far as I'm aware that's contained within
the companies and my concern is that we
don't
you know just it's just a one-liner in
this report
um and obviously that's where we're
doing new work we're using large there's
large sums of money involved etc etc so
where is it documented
um
why don't we see this as there's a
separate report that's going to come
here
um if you could just answer those for me
thanks
to that because I think that would be
quite a good idea
um all the companies do have um separate
risk registers um so the five companies
and there's an overall
um risk meeting
um
across across the five
um on a quarterly basis
um that we that we attend and give
advice on on risk two so the cabinet
members responsible for the
sit on that so it's a group along with a
Lea attack
but there's there's no reason why we we
can't bring more on the company's risk
Arrangements
so I said my last point and I'm sure
someone else has got some
um that on um page 27 it talks about an
event that will could interfere with the
council's business model
um but it's not kind of clear
from this what what we mean by the by
business model
um because again for me that's that's
absolutely everything that the council
is doing but I'm not quite sure
um
what's that what that's meaning and if
we're including
again all of the companies and
everything within that so if you could
just sort of explain that for me thank
you very much yep that's no problem
um so we're talking now about business
continuity
um so events like Cyber attack
um fire flood
um those sort of events so making sure
that our business continuity
arrangements are picked up in this risk
register uh
service risk questions as well and we've
started to do work and Truth has had
conversation just last week about
business continuity arrangements and the
integration with risk management and
that's
no no I just I just wanted to say that I
think you know as you said you thought
it was a good idea chair if we if we I
think also if if with the
um more of a culture of looking at risk
management that's been introduced as you
know as has been recommended to the
council I think one it's great that
we're actually doing doing all that and
it's good to see
um you know that we've got people here
now that are going to be responsible and
help us achieve that but equally you
know if we are being responsible for it
we need to actually see the entire risk
picture for the councils and so to have
a report on the on the companies
um and and the risk involved with that I
think we we all need to be clear
um what that what the risks are to the
council so I think that would be really
school thank you thank you I think that
would be very
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
your chair that's uh seven vote sport so
that's unanimous thank you very much
indeed
right I now like to move on to a gender
item number eight which is Jac
2137 and I would now like to invite Jan
Robinson the deputy monitoring officer
to present the report please thank you
Jan
thank you chair um I'm not going to say
too much this is the standard report
um for the past year and councilors can
see the detailed breakdown of um the
code of conduct complaints that we've
received obviously we can't go into the
detail specifically but that gives you a
flavor really of what we we're dealing
with and happy to take any questions
thank you
um one thing that stood out from this
was the um the issue of a formal warning
for a counselor on non-disclosure of
interest
um I know you can't really talk about
the exact detail of that but um
is that is a formal warning adequate
though is that do we do we take that far
enough for non-disclosure revision
interests
so non-disposable interests is not a
criminal offense it's the pecuniary
interest which is the criminal offense
so if it was a formal warning for a
pecuniary interest it would be the
police actually detailing them and
cautioning people but for
um non-registerable interest we can only
um you know send a formal letter saying
actually if you progress you you are we
are going to take it further and you
will you know be in breach of the code
of conduct so they will get a formal
letter but as I say it is the difference
between and with the new code of
conducts as well with other registerable
interest and non-registerable interest
as I say neither of those are are
criminal so it is down to the monitoring
officer to do
um what they can with the sanctions that
they have available to them and a formal
warning is what we would do and
recommend probably training further
training or code of conduct
it's just in this it just says an
interest if that could say number Canary
yeah and that that would be really
helpful but yeah thank you yeah you've
explained it really well thank you
yeah the the
um yeah I'm I'm a member of the the
um joint Standards Board
um which we share with the these two
councils with the County Council
um so I was just interested to to
explore with with what the officers said
um
at what point does that escalate to to
something that we're going to take to to
the ball that I'm a member of so with
the joint standard subcommittee we
available to to them um the ability to
take
um a case where it's so serious that we
want counselors to to actually look at
it and and to decide what sanctions or
the other the other
um
case is when
um we don't we we
um give a sanction to a counselor they
don't undertake that sanction because if
you remember their only recommendations
that we can give and if counselors
refuse to do it the next step is to take
them to Joint standard subcommittee and
cancer I think you've been a party to a
few where they haven't undertaken the
sanctions
um imposed by the monitoring officer
not interested
obviously seriously
also a non-compliant
yes yes
do you have the ability to um take that
into an independent
investigation so we do so when as I say
with um you know depending on the
serious nature of of the complaint and
hopefully most of them are not that
serious that we have to but where
there's serious allegations we we can
appoint an independent investigation and
indeed we have done so in the past where
the allegations have been so great that
you you just want somebody independent
completely to look at it and that's as
well as the independent persons so the
independent person would also be
involved in actually looking at her to
decide whether it does go to Independent
investigation and it's not just the
monitoring officer thinking you know
it's the balance and checks really to
stop us sort of you know getting too
carried away if you like but then once
the investigator has come back with
their findings it then also goes back to
a new independent person for them to
have a look at and say actually I'm
looking at that and it sort of regulates
it a bit so
um they can look at it and say yeah
actually I'm in agreement with it or I
think it's too harsh or too lenient so
there's sort of checks and balances
along the way that we can put in but yes
we do use an independent investigators
and we do use our IPS
no
okay
well the recommendation is that the code
of conduct complaints monitoring
information obtained in paper Jack 22 21
37 be noted so we don't actually need to
vote on that particular paper moving on
to agenda item number nine this is Jack
2138 and I'd like to introduce Rebecca
Hewitt corporate manager for finance
commissioning and procurement to talk
about the report please thank you
Rebecca
thank you chair and this is the joint
treasury management report covering the
position for the first six months of the
financial year 2022-23
provides details of performance effects
of decision decisions taken during that
period and compliance with the council's
treasury management policy
the report explains the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic
interest rates and liquidity risk
the economic backdrop during the April
to September period continued to be
characterized by high oil gas and
commodity prices ongoing High inflation
and its impact on customers
call of living no imminent end in sight
to the Russian Ukraine hostilities and
its Associated impact on the supply
chain
and in addition China's zero covered
policy
interest rates have climbed with the
bank rate increasing from 0.75 in March
to 2.25 by the end of September
the bank of England has since increased
it further to three percent in November
with the majority of the committee
judging that further increases may still
be required
for our two councils for both councils
banking activities undertaken were
within the daily bank account limits
each Council has reduced its debt favor
by 7.3 million and mid-suffered by 7
million
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix C of the report
the council's pooled funds excluding the
ccla have experienced a drop in
valuation this half of the year but an
increase in the rate of return compared
to 2122
both councils are compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the half year was done so in priority
order of security and liquidity over
yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
I'm now happy to take any questions from
members on this report
yeah
um
inevitably I ask
um
how are we doing in looking at the
um
let's say the consistency of our
treasury management
um with with our climate change 2030 Net
Zero objective
foreign
thank you and we are having ongoing
discussions with our advisors about any
new new investment opportunities
um but as decided pre previously we will
need to wait until our investments are
at a position where we can trade them
um as they are currently still the value
is still less than than our original
investment on the
on them yes so so you're saying that at
the moment
we're showing losses
which we will crystallize
if if we if we shifted out of fossil
fuels basically
that is correct yes
yeah
did
yeah I mean it's a little surprising
that we're still showing losses when
um the the you know the oil and gas
companies are showing astronomical
profits um
how's that how's that so I would have
thought they'd been going up
knocked down
or is that compared to historical
um purchase prices of the of the
Investments
don't have that tell with me I'm afraid
but I've
ought to go away and have a look at that
but it will depend on the makeup of the
fund so
um the each of the funds has a
widespread of investments in lots of
different types of
types of Investments and um and shares
so I would have to go and have a look at
the exact makeup of that fund to see
where that where those losses have gone
thank you very much
um in table four
um treasury investment position there's
other pooled funds as a title in there
could you just give me a um
oh sorry
um page 63.
um I'll give you time to find out where
I am
so other pooled funds could you can just
talk a bit about what that is
yeah sure thank you that is the the
pulled fund portfolio so that's the
Schroeder's fund um the UBS
the ccla and the 91 in first deck
investment fund as well as the funding
Circle so that is that collection that
11 million is that collection of of
pooled funds
um the other the banks and building
societies is is basically what we have
in the council's current accounts and
then money market funds are a day-to-day
cash Investments to balance our cash
flow yeah oh okay so that yeah they're
all together in the paper so yeah that's
nice and easy thank you and um
in table five on page
65 investment benchmarking
it talks about bail in exposure there is
a bit about it I know in 1.12
on the next page but you can just
explain to me that what that means the
99
bail in exposure
and what that whether that's good or bad
I'm struggling with it I'm sorry
thank you
okay yes sir
um I will I'm afraid to say I'll have to
take that one away and get some more
advice from our advisors on on that one
but I'll come back to you on that
okay thank you
um thank you chair I too was going to
ask about bailing um exposure because to
me that
says we've got high bailing exposure and
I wanted to know
um
why we're doing that and why we've got a
strategy of of that so um
that's if if
Rebecca's going to come back to us on
that then
that would be good but I
didn't think that fitted with our more
cautious approach
um my second question was on
on that same page page 66 the 1.16 this
um statutory override issue
and
I just wanted to to know if you've got
any more information on that
um
as in what you know with the current
consultation what impact that might have
um on the on the pooled funds you know
the cclas the schroders and so on and
when can we
and and at the at the moment as the
consultation is I don't know when it
finishes all the decisions going to be
but
if it's suggested that it increases in
those
um
the value goes into a reserve when then
could we use those Reserves
um
to you know take that how long you have
to keep them in the reserve and when can
you use it thank you chair
yes thank you and we have not yet had
the outcome of that consultation so
they're still working through all of
that
um in terms of what that means for our
our paper valuation losses that we have
at the moment
um we would have to work that through
but I would
usually in this instance is we might see
some kind of mitigation for those that
are already on the books
um
in terms of Reserve movements going
forward
um
the the idea would be that we would put
those any increases into reserves to
mitigate against future losses
again I will have to see what the
outcome of that consultation is um as to
further further guidance on what they
expect us to do with those
um so we don't know
so the consultation is still open or is
it finished
the consultation is finished they have
not yet okay
um could I ask then share that when when
we
when that um when the response is
received that we just get a note saying
what what has the outcome is because in
terms of whether we'll need to put
um funds into reserves and so on
and thanks and can I ask a second
question
um on um page 72
um
we've got a table for
um
the I don't know what they're calling
that trading company's activity on on
all the other tables in the report and
we show what the initial investment has
been
so you can kind of but whereas on this
table all you've got is movements over
the last few years and I was wondering
if we can actually ensure that we show
the initial investment because otherwise
it it doesn't provide a complete picture
thank you
hey yes I can take that away and we'll
look to include that in future
okay actually with Casey claston please
um so the next page from where we were
um table nine um page 73 investment
limits
um it seems that we
over invested in Lloyd's Bank
is the um we went over our set
investment limit
um and we've um we've not complied there
um could you talk a bit about that and
what's happened whether it's been put
right and have there been any penalties
um of any kind through
through doing that
73 and um we've got table nine
investment limits and um then when we go
into mid-suffolk the the top
um box on their Lloyds Bank
um we've got a um investment limit of 2
million and we've um
we've
we've gone to 2.5 which I I assume is
the reason why the um that's triggered
the non-compliant
I don't I don't think this is a serious
issue at all um but I'd just like to
hear a bit more about it
really
um and I've I've just noticed that is
potentially inconsistent with the text
underneath so I'll take that away and
look at that with the team as well
um but usually when that happens it will
be a late income that we weren't
expecting and that will be our our
Lloyds Bank that's our current account
that the councils use so there's no
penalty for that
um it's purely there as a risk
management tool to make sure that we're
not holding too much in one place and
that we're not losing out on on interest
income by having too much sitting in
that account so there's no penalties and
no no notifications for that so yeah
purely an exposure
the risk management
limit and it there's no there's been no
penalty at all
no okay thank you
thank you for raising that cage the
castle that was the very question I was
going to raise myself actually so thank
you for rating that as well okay we're
now moving to debate
uh we'll wait for case of Madison to
come back he did mention that he wished
to raise something in debate
they can come back
to do that do any other members wish to
start off the debate kill cancer
Mathison returns to chamber
case your ego thank you it's not it's
not really the debate church just some
of the the um
the the report it's uh it's quite a
couple it's quite complex report there's
lots of different things in it but
um it feels somehow
that's right that some things are kind
of
um repeated several times and other
things aren't and and I'm just kind of
I find myself kind of shift shifting
about back and forth and I just wonder
if we can just have a look at
you know and pull out some of the key
things and I've written notes saying you
know should be in main report or
whatever so that the the key the key
highlights
um come out but also
um so that's just a sort of technical
not really a debate form and then I just
feel that
um
some of the things that we've raised
here I've got slightly hidden a bit so
like the sort of thing about the bailing
or the override and and
um
you know whereas I would expect those to
be sort of pulled out in the
up front as it were but but generally
you know I know I appreciate it's a
complex area and I know the offices work
really hard to pull this together so I'm
not you know it's just to make things
easier for for us
so I can't remember it must have been
the it was the October one or the
September one I definitely remember that
we mentioned that because I know that
Rebecca sent me a report and I didn't
mention that so we were actually aware
of that and thank you again for raising
that question on that I'd like now to
move into debate in case the master
value you wish to raise something in
debate that you mentioned earlier
yes thank you yeah I think I think the
um
what what I'm looking for really is is
that
um our treasury management strategy
is Shifting to that complete consistency
with 20 30. it's interesting that the
um the county pension committee
apparently last week
um there was an increased recognition of
the of the need you know that the
strategy was not consistent with with
net net zero
um 2030 and it and that therefore
the offices of that committee would be
bringing forward
changes to strategy to go in that
direction
so that there was
a plan ahead
that would lead
to
achieve in 2030 in regard of of the
Investments of the pension fund which of
course are enormous and
um
far more than we've got here but
nevertheless the same point about
consistency applies I think and
um
yes I think that's the uh oh yes yeah
there was yeah the second Point really
was that the
um I think councilor casting was it
um no not cancer ebone raised the
question that the um the Baseline
was different for the companies
of of where we were comparing with with
previous year whereas when you answered
my question about the
um the fact that we hadn't
we hadn't taken any steps
recently because because we would show
losses that would would crystallize
um I think really my point is is that
at some point we need to make a judgment
that the the Investments
in oil and gas are historically High
even though they might not be as good as
they were when we bought them and if
inevitably they're going to go down and
the and the the usual phrase is is
stranded assets if you've probably heard
that phrase that um
if their balance sheets are based on
a lot of
oil oil and gas that's in the ground
and and
the United Nations are saying and and
the council has resolved a couple of
years ago similarly that we need
to do a lot about that then we need to
be bringing forward that Judgment at
some point say well we're going to take
half a million
quid hit on our balance sheet
in this next financial year
um
if we get rid of this but we ought to do
it now rather than leaving it because if
we leave it for another year we might be
taking a showing a million or a million
and a half loss on that balance sheet
and and so see what I'm arguing is is
that we we need to move to that judgment
because you know ultimately the loss is
there
and if the loss is going to get bigger
rather than smaller then there's all the
more reason to to actually get on with
it
in keeping with our Council Net Zero
objective thank you
Rebecca
thank you Rebecca thank you cage the
castle you had
debate um I might be able to help with
that a little bit
um the reason why we're not seeing a big
change in the funds um value because of
the oil and gas going up is
um because it's a very small part of it
there's only from last time I looked I
was trying to get out now but I didn't
quite get it up in time last time I
looked it was only a very small part of
the Schroeder fund that was in oil and
gas
um it was um
I'm struggling to um
think that it was more than double
figures in percentage points so none of
the other funds are
invested even um to a level where it's
reportable
um so you they'll be made of they'll be
made of other accounts that might have
oil and gas as part of their investment
so by that time it's very small so um
the actual amount in our investments
um that's in oil and gas is a very very
small amount once you put all the funds
together you take that one investment
which I think is um
um be on petroleum
um
or or whatever
um the um
by the time you've you've spread that
across it it's a really small part so it
would make very little difference
um but I still do think these
Investments are doing
doing all right considering the current
climate there's not really any place
that money's been in the last um you
know in this this last couple of months
two or three months that hasn't lost a
lot of um book cost the um
the and and they did respond to um the
Improvement in the market very quickly
and got back up to um where they them
where they've been bought so um yeah I
hope that's gone some way to explain in
it I my guess would be
it is um the oil and gas investment in
our funds is probably around two percent
if that I wouldn't expect it to be any
more
um but obviously it'd be very hard to
work out because you have to look at
each individual individual Equity Fund
and everything that's involved in there
and see what they've got in and
probably be over a thousand
but yeah thank you thank you in case we
go please thank you
thank you thank you chair and thank you
councilor custom and councilman
um I think perhaps we could we could um
actually understand what that is because
on on the thing that I raise every time
I didn't today but I know I am is at the
bottom of page 48 we talk about
considering withdrawing from funds and
it
um
in terms of meeting the environmental
social and governance considerations
um
and that's not just environmentalist
social as well but so we don't really
get an understanding of
you know
what
um
you know ccla invested in what
Schroeders invested in what UBS invest
in so and therefore
you know oil and gas is at one tiny bit
of it but there may be I mean there may
not be but there may be something else
that that we would think well actually
that doesn't fit with the council's
values
um
so you know and that line there comes up
each on each report saying
are considering but there's no there's
never any movement on from that so I
think that would be be useful to follow
up in in some form or other energy
is that possible yep
um yeah certainly so I know we'll be
bringing our treasury strategy for next
year back in January so I can look to
incorporate some information on what's
in invested in as part of each of those
funds as part of that that would be
thank you very much thank you thank you
casa Matheson yeah I think I might might
just briefly answer
um Council caston's Point
um the the pension the pension um fund
what what they have have done
in part is I think they shifted half
their
um their their
funds similar to the the Schroeder one
he was talking about uh what I can't
remember which one it was but they um
there was there were two options
available
and one of which was a sort of all all
share option and the other one was was
actually a filtered option which was
called the the climate aware fund which
basically had all the all the same
um shares in it except for the except
for the ones that were filtered out on
on grounds of um of oil and gas and
fossil fuel and um
so if you if you actually make that
shift
crystallize the
um the loss that we're carrying but at
the same time
you don't effectively lose anything but
you do get yourselves out of the last
bit of fossil fuel and accepting as you
say that it may not be a huge part of
the of of that particular fund but I
think that you know that 11.2 is good
that we've
um we're looking at the the ESG reports
um and I guess what I'm asking is that
we we take more action on them thank you
thank you to matter do any other members
wish to enter the debate please
thank you very much for making this
based on those Rebecca that's much
appreciated thank you right well in view
if there's no further debate I will now
go to the vote for this item and there
will be three votes for this one the
first vote is for both councils the
second one for Baylor members only and
the third one for mid-suffolk members
only so the first recommendation 3.1 on
page 45 is that the treasury management
activity for the first six months of
2223 are set out in this report an
appendices be noted can I have a
proposer and a second to place
just that's with both cases came to
Caston and councilor Owen thank you very
much and we can now go to the electronic
vote which is now open thank you members
thank you chair that's seven votes for
thank you very much Mandy
recommendations 3.2 this is for baby
council members only that have been
noted that baber District council's
treasury management activity for the
first six months of 2223 was in
accordance with the approved treasury
management strategy and that the council
has complied with all the treasury
management indicators for this period so
can I have a proposal and a second
different Behavior members councilor
Huron and casual and thank you very much
that vote is
now open for you thank you
chairperson thank you very much indeed
right recommendation 3.3 for Mid Suffolk
members only and that it is to be noted
that mid-suffolk District council's
treasury management activity for the
first six months of 22-23 was in
accordance with the approved treasury
management strategy and that except for
one occasion when the council exceed its
daily bank account limit with Lloyd as
mentioned in appendix C paragraph four
that Capital has complied with all the
treasury management indicators for this
bearish so can I have a proposer and a
second
thanks to Captain and Caitlin Norris
thank you very much and that the vote is
now open thank you
chair that's five votes for thank you
very much Mandy we now move on to agenda
item 10 and that's Jac
2139 and I'd like to ask Jon Snow as the
corporate manager for internal audit to
present his report thank you John
thank you chair and good morning members
so the the purpose of this report that
you have in front of you is to inform
you of the work undertaken within the
internal audit service for the first
half year
2022-23
and it also provides your sales with a
review of the variety of of work scope
the projects and the corporate
activities which are supported through
the work of the team
I just like to bring across some key
messages which I think are important at
this stage just to give you a flavor of
what's happening within the audit world
and the sort of the assurance that we
provide across both authorities
um it's important to to ascertain really
that the demand on internal audit
Services continues uh in terms of the
level of assurance that we Supply the
support the guidance particularly as the
council still looks to reshape and
transform its services
and in line with the internal audit
Charter again just to provide members
with that level of assurance
it does cover the areas of work that
does cover the public sector internal
audit standards which allows me to
produce an annual internal audit report
an opinion at the year end so the work
that we actually undertake covers things
like the governance processes the
monitoring Arrangements which is like
the management oversight ethical
behaviors and that's things about gifts
and hospitalities Declarations of
interest that sort of work information
governance and you'll see within the
plan that was earlier
provided to you and signed off is around
data quality So currently we're working
very closely with the director Sarah
Wilcox and her team around data quality
and also the work that falls under my
responsibility around counter fraud
management again a separate report comes
to you at year end
so in terms of actually delivering the
work the resources come from existing
staff and also the external audit
partner
this Arrangement continues to work well
and allows a direct internal provision
plus the commissioning of external
skills and a capacity that provides a
blend of resources from within the
council and also from our external
partner which is tier which has been
mentioned earlier in one of the reports
moving on to appendix a and the work
that's been undertaken you may recall
back in 2021-22 my annual report to this
committee that the planning enforcement
received an audit opinion on the control
of our environment of limited assurance
in line with our own internal order
procedures disorder was followed up
earlier this year
although there were some other issues
that we identified resulting in another
further follow-up I am now pleased to
report to members that all the
recommendations have been implemented by
management and that audit opinion has
now been raised to reasonable assurance
I would also draw members attention to
uh again within appendix a to the
general ledger review which again
received an audit opinion of limited
assurance and again in line with our own
practices will be followed up shortly uh
early next year and the results of that
follow-up will be reported back to this
committee year end as part of my annual
report
the full status of the report excuse me
of this report is detailed in section
five of appendix a together with a
summary of all the audits undertaken to
date
um as well as conducting audit reviews
internal audit I've also had significant
involvement within a uh within the
period and a variety of different
Council activities
this includes leading on the production
of the annual governance statement for
2122 which was presented earlier this
year
also my attendance at the statutory
offices working group which is to
provide appropriate professional
determinational governance matters as
they arrive
full details of the anti-fraud and
Corruption workers I've just mentioned
it will be brought to you in March for
last year
uh until recently uh well I say recently
I was part of the technical management
team uh responsible for managing
emerging risks and Direction resources
and that was around the covid and now um
as that sort of subsiding
um my professional Insight is only now
called upon when it's required
um there's a member of my staff which
continues to support the council's
business sale um she provides Assurance
on the administration of the various
business grants
announced by central government and more
recently the energy rebate payment this
work includes ensuring that the
prescribed criteria in terms of the
eligibility is correctly applied and
meets with the managing of the risk of
Fraud and a number of digital Assurance
tools we used to highlight those
there are no additional related order
issues that currently need to be brought
to your attention these days so I'm
happy to take questions that you may
have
to please counselor Caston and then
Council
thank you Mr chairman and yeah I think a
lot of it's been dealt with by um the
officer and um explaining it
um what I was interested in was the um
the new safeguarding
um part of the audit
um
I the has that um have we got that in
place
yet
um because obviously we're we're right
at the
um end date and I wouldn't mind hearing
a little bit about
about that safeguarding audit and the
work that's going on with that because I
think that's a really important I'm
really pleased to see it added in there
I think that you know that that's really
good too if you could talk on that thank
you yeah yeah thank you uh council is it
I I share your concern in the sense that
I think it's very important not just for
officers but also for members as well
particularly the role that you play out
in the districts as well being aware of
the legislation and requirements
particularly reporting things so this
was an audit that was pushed into this
year as a result of conversations I've
had with one of our directors
so we would be looking at
um certainly the legislative Duty that
the councils have both at officer level
and also member level so we'll be
looking to see what training is
available to to both sects and ensuring
that refresher training is adequate so
we've sort of started that audit and my
auditor has spoken to Vicki Mosley and I
know there have been some changes in
staff which escalates the risk to make
sure there aren't any gaps but that is
in the
moment so hopefully
that will be completed as said by the
end of November I know that
unfortunately we're slightly
it has slipped and that's the result of
one of the two key officers that we
wanted to have a conversation with
wasn't available at the time but it will
never at least be completed ASAP and
Vicky Mosley who's acutely aware of the
need to actually escalate this up so we
can actually report back to this this
committee
um
so um when you when you say it's uh
we're looking at into the management is
that
um looking at how that filters down to
the actual staff on the ground
um how would we how do we because for me
safeguarding almost starts with the
boots on the ground the people you know
um that are actually doing doing work in
some aspect it depends what aspect of
safeguarding it is but um does is that
looking to um filter safeguarding
training down to staff members that meet
with the public and um absolutely
there's more of a focus I think In
fairness
um what we will do in terms of looking
at that training aspect we'll be looking
at the officers responsible for that
training and getting it down a group
Grassroots so even myself I don't go out
very rarely I don't meet members of the
public but having said that I still need
to have a responsibility that if I do
come across a particular instant I know
how to deal with it and who to report it
to so it's for everybody but more so
those Frontline offices where there's
greater exposure potentially greater
exposure that we need to have that
greater understanding and particularly
how we report how
not just leave it there on the table and
nothing's done about it so we are
acutely aware of what those risks are
but we need to understand what that
level of training is and is it adequate
to not only members but also officers
all right thank you chair excuse me on
page 85 put in the audits conducted on
the general ledger protection on page 85
which has already been referred to
by the corporate manager for internal
audit it mentions within the purpose of
audit reconciliations between the host
and feeder systems to ensure that
posting accuracy and financial Integrity
are assured
findings it says reconciliations of the
principal control regards for the time
of testing found before perform
regularly on a timely basis however
there was no secondary check to ensure
that accuracy and further down that
management have accepted the
recommendations and advisor review the
whole process around these
reconciliations will be undertaken
Etc and the opinion on that is limited
Insurance follow-up to the undertaken
during
2012-23 but my question is is this
appears to be sort of Fairly
oh important
is there a Target date for completion of
this work
please
they're coming yeah thank you councilor
yes so we'll be undertaking that work
early next year in the new calendar year
and that's something that I'll be having
a conversation with Rebecca and her team
to ensure that we actually do the
follow-up as promptly as we possibly can
there is a level Assurance in fact the
reconciliations are being carried out
and a tiny basis but the point we were
trying to raise and I'm sure Rebecca
will be able to support me that is
actually having that killed sign off so
it's okay me doing a Reconciliation for
example but that's just me I need a
secondary signatory to check that what
I've reconciled is actually accurate and
there's also the element around the
section 151 reports which are being
produced but we need to have that
management oversight and I know speaking
to Rebecca and Melissa they've got that
in hand and that's part of the
transformational program within the
finance Arena that we're actually
looking at
can I just ask and you are confident and
that this work can be completely in a
relatively short period of time oh yes I
can do counts like it very much
um thank you chair um I he was going to
ask about General lecture in the timing
of that um particularly as we're looking
at budgets at the moment but so thanks
for those answers
um my other two points are on on
contracts um
John you've mentioned the um you know
again that that's being looked at again
in the new year but I'm not clear
because I understood that there was a
lot of work going on within contact
management and procurement and a
particular project over the last
I'm not sure how long you're here six
months here
um to which somebody was allocated to
you know a separate team or more person
or whatever to do that so I was just a
bit
um
concerned that that's
not kind of come through into the
internal audits I just wondered if you
could
um come on comment on that please
yeah yeah thank you councilor so um on
page 84 uh I think that's where you're
talking around the contract management
so
um it seems an age ago so don't quote me
on the dates on that but we had the east
of England LGA do some work uh they were
undertaken they were commissioned to do
a piece of work then we had the height
of covid so it was all pushed back and
the report was delayed and delayed it
has since been issued there had to be a
period of embedment before we came along
and actually did almost a health check
so that piece of work has actually been
done and the results are there on page
84 to supplement that piece of work
we're also doing another piece of work
in quarter four around contract spend
which will tie in with this piece of
work that we've just Undertake and this
was a consultancy piece of work which we
agreed with Catherine Steele at the time
now Melissa uh and also working
obviously with the CMP team which
obviously sits now under under Rebecca
um so that work in terms of the contract
has the contract management has been
undertaken but we're going to be doing
some more work as I say in quarter four
which is around uh contract spend and so
which will tie in
um with the the results and findings of
that contract management piece of work
um that yeah okay thanks very much for
that um I've got a second question if I
may which is on housing so um top of
page 80
um seven when looking at Council house
um rent setting where it says work in
progress so I just wondered whether
you know what does the um I see the kind
of
detail layer saying you know what's
um how it is being addressed you know
whether they're
what the risks and so on are but I just
wanted to know does that actually
include consideration of external
factors such as you know inflation and
the cost of living and so forth or was
it is it more of an internal approach
thank you
yeah I think because it's more of an
actual internal rather than the external
factors that are going on and we've
actually just as you said it's completed
by the end of uh this this month
um the draft reports been issued we're
just waiting for merchant response but
the initial audit opinion that it's come
out as reasonable Assurance in terms of
that Council rent setting and obviously
the Auditors here have been in close
conversations with uh Robert longfoot
who is the corporate manager responsible
for that
but no it was more of an internal piece
of work and having that level of
assurance particularly as Robert's
relatively new as the corporate manager
and again that sort of piece of work was
agreed at the beginning of the year
yes you you did just mention already the
the LGA peer review
um I was going to ask
um really whether you
you felt that the the recommendations
and I think that we're talking about two
peer reviews here the the the the
peer review on planning which was a
which was in relation to mid-suffer
specifically but also I think that the
other uh more General Corporate peer
review was was um was across the whole
organization
um whether you felt that those
um recommendations have been carried
through there was a certain perception
in our group that um they weren't only
been
a long time in arriving but also the
degree to which they were actually being
implemented
okay that's uh thank you councilor
that's
no um it's not part of our plan for this
year so we did planning enforcement
um but we've not actually done anything
on sort of the planning so the part that
planning review
um I haven't been called upon to do any
audit uh work to support or provide any
degrees of level of assurance on that so
that's something that presumably Tom
Barker and the planning team would
actually be taking on board and moving
that one forwards
I'm trying
I'm not the answer we need in mind
not quite
a clear way
s to all these things starts and
finishes
um
I mean in terms of the the
peer review if you like there is a
program of work to address those
findings
yes yeah and they are being dressed
through SLT yeah yeah
so they will be addressed and so
obviously the findings there's a program
to replicate in terms of what those
issues were addressed and how they're
going to be addressed moving forward but
that's something that you may need to
speak directly with
barking for
questions please I talked then would any
member like to debate
this paper
no
okay thank you very much indeed John for
your report well this report is for
noting only and the recommendation was
that the content of this internal audit
report supported by appendix a be noted
so there's no vote on that particular
paper moving on to the next one which is
Jac
2140 which is the forward work plan
committee plan
um
do we have any comments or questions any
character even please
um thank you chair I know that in
January we've got
statement of accounts and Auditors
report for 2020 stroke 21.
um
I'm I'm assuming
well I'm not assuming anything actually
why is that 2021 20 sorry
why is that from 18 months ago and also
I know that in the past we've had issues
with the external
timing of the external Auditor's report
and so on and I just wanted to wanted a
view on that and when we might expect
the following years as well thank you
thank you Katie uh John are you able to
answer that question
I actually might pass it to my learning
colleague who's sitting on my left thank
you
2021 audit started in March
this year they then had to go and finish
the NHS audit so they didn't get that
completed so they are due to come back
and complete that audit
um imminently in I need to have a common
with them whether we will be able to
come back in January without signed off
or whether it may be delayed further and
we've not yet got a date for them to
come in and do the 22-23 audit and I
imagine that that is going to be into 23
24 before they they're able to come in
and complete battled it
can I come back without saying that
that's just
um
just trying to think of a proper word to
use other than that's mad but um the um
is that I presume that all
councils were in a similar situation
there's nothing we can do we can't kind
of you know say
um we won't pay them all but not won't
pay them but you know we want to things
to be moved along because
you know otherwise I think that that's
you know that is a serious issue in
terms of because for all we know there
might be some issues on the on the
accounts you know I'm not saying there
are but that we all should be aware of
and that we're then carrying through
daily carrying through to the following
year but we don't know about it because
it's it's well out you know it's well
out of date as it were so I don't know I
suppose my question is is there any
pressure we can bear anywhere to to get
that one actually get that one in
January and secondly get the 21 22
um accounts sooner then then these ones
are appearing thanks
um yes we're having uh conversations
with them on timing unfortunately we're
in a position where because they have
delayed the timing is then not helpful
for us trying to do budgets at the same
time so that then causes further delays
um and you know it's been difficult to
to catch up and get back on the correct
cycle we're not unique in that it's
fairly common especially among smaller
District councils who don't necessarily
have the specialist resources to to
throw our audit and accounts
um but yes we can we'll keep pushing to
to get it done
very important question actually so
thank you for raising that case Libra uh
Casey Matheson please yeah that that is
actually quite alarming I mean if if the
council was was a company had been
struck off by now and um I suppose the
government has given some sort of um
dispensational or whatever on it but it
it does kind of
um take me to the question of the
um the our companies
various companies audits
um now that they're actually being
carried out by separate people
um presumably to a to a more timely
timetable
um
but
even there the I seem to remember at
least some of those companies are
effectively
um
guaranteed underwritten by letters of
comfort or whatever from the council
saying yeah we'll look after this
company because it's ours
um although we know it's insolvent at
the moment Etc
um it seems to be a bit of a bit of an
uncomfortable area there
the back of these
yeah thank you there's probably not too
much I can comment on there I'm not
overly familiar with the whole process
around their accounts I do know that the
company's accounts are prepared
separately and audited separately as
well so we do we do get those in a
timely fashion
on any of those as far as you know
you know the lateness
no no we're not
okay so do we have any other suggestions
comments or amendments to the forward
plan at all
no well I'd like to that conclude the
meeting so thank you very much indeed
for attending this morning the next
meeting is currently scheduled for
Monday the 30th of January 2023 at 10
30. so I'd like to thank Rebecca John uh
Mandy Jan Henriette and Alicia and
members obviously for this morning's
meeting thank you all very much thank
you the meeting is now close thank you